[Music]
after life by Ricky Gervais has just
dropped on Netflix and it's arguably one
of the densest and most emotional
comedies that the creator has ever
written the show deals with a lot in its
six Episode run and throughout this
video I'll be breaking down some of the
biggest takeaways from the series
including my own personal thoughts on it
this is full spoilers ahead so if you
don't want to know anything about
afterlife then I highly recommend that
you turn off now but with that out of
the way i'm definition welcome to the
channel and let's dive into my spoiler
review of after life after life follows
tony played by ricky gervais who has
recently lost his wife and in doing so
also lost his meaningful living similar
to Gervase in real life Tony is an
atheist who really seems to struggle
with just how cruel and unfair that life
can be at certain times the character is
brutal to those around him suicidal and
also completely unwilling to accept
health as he States the one thing that
would make him happy which is the return
of his wife is completely impossible
this is a man who is really at
rock-bottom and the season deals with
him coming to grips with the fact that
life does have its redeeming qualities
Tony works for a paper and deals with
their ridiculous stories such as a local
baby that looks like Adolf Hitler a damp
stain that looks like Kenneth Branagh
and a boy who can play two recorders
through his nostrils it's on these
journeys that Tony after hearing the
life stories of those he is mocking
comes to realize that he hasn't been
singled out everyone in their life has
been dull a bad hand and has had to
recover from it which begins to inspire
him by the end of the series Tony comes
to realize that in loss there is also
the opportunity to regain and grow
though the people he encounters too had
to deal with their own tragedies they
managed to learn from it accept it and
treasure the precious memories that they
have left
Tony accepts that though he doesn't
believe in an afterlife that doesn't
mean that life is pointless
he states we should appreciate what we
have as we never know when it's going to
be taken away one day you will hug the
purse
love for the last time and not even know
it this adds value to every moment and
Tony regains his appreciation for the
world around him and all its
magnificence but me the most touching
moment in the piece comes from when Tony
visits his father in the final episode
and know he has severe dementia his
father recognizes his son and one of
their happiest memories together comes
back on the surface the story of Tony
painting the wall in their house would
be perhaps a negative one however the to
look back on it fondly and smile which
to me sums up the message of the show
even things we think are bad come to
have their own beauty and magic to them
that we will one day look back upon
fondly because it made up our lives by
the end Andi learns that the trick to a
happy life is to find who is nice and
who isn't and spend the precious time
that we do have with the former this is
symbolized by him cutting out his
therapist and instead turning to his
brother Matt for consolation realizing
that the two will have more of a
connection and will be able to heal each
other rather than relying on an outsider
matt has a failing marriage and inspired
by Tony he decides to work on it and
repair his life to me Matt is the true
winner here as he manages to succeed in
keeping Tony alive long enough to
realize that he doesn't want to kill
himself
Tony confesses how much that he loves
the people around him and that he can't
live without them and know he deals with
loss he also accepts it Tony finally
asks out his father's nurse and they to
begin a new life together happy at what
they have and what it could lead to
after life is about learning to love
again after loss whilst this could
primarily be thought of as just Tony
re-engaging in a relationship it also
has to do with the love of life the
world and the people in it it's a truly
powerful message and the piece works as
an excellent mental health case study
that showcases that though we will all
face tragedy that too has its own beauty
and that the meaning of life
[Music]
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on afterlife and if you enjoyed it make
sure you leave your review in the
comments below and let me know if you
took anything different from the show as
I'd love to read it if you enjoyed this
video then please like it and make sure
you check out my breakdown of this
weekend's other big release Captain
Marvel which will be linked after this
video
this is the channel for people who are
never missing television
so if that's the kind of thing you like
you need to subscribe to definition
thanks again for taking the time to
watch this you've been the best and I'll
see you next time take care peace
[Music]